hi my name is Amna
I'm an engineer on the Android project
and today I want to tell you about an
exciting key feature of our platform
every application on an Android system
is able to create background services we
can perform background tasks on your
behalf while you're busy doing something
entirely different I have an application
right here that I want to show you in
the demonstrate this feature this
application lets you manage a list of
buddies from their website Flickr and
when I click on a buddy
I can see all these photos from the
website now I really like these photos
and I don't want to check every hour or
every day there's a new photo available
so the application is smart enough to
start a background service in the wall
I'm using for instance the web browser
and doing other tasks the application
will keep checking the account in the
background and will send me a
notification as soon as a new photo is
available so here I just got a
notification about a new photo I just
pulled the status bar and when I click
on the notification I get right back to
the photos and I can see the new photo
for this buddy available in the
application